all right everybody welcome back we've
got a special episode
for you special episode alert today is
our 2021
bold predictions episode what does that
mean we are going to make
we being andrew myself and a special
guest
carly riley who was the finance director
on our 2020 presidential run in a
complete superstar in many many ways we
are going to make some predictions for
the year
and here's the deal the winner
if you get them right um we're gonna
we're gonna bet on them
um so if you're listening to these use
the hashtag
yangspeakswager and let us know what we
should bet on them because i think it's
more fun if you guys tell us what dumb
things we do
right or wrong so tune in the yang speak
special bold predictions for 2021 with
carly
riley coming up right now
[Music]
welcome back we have a
special episode alert for yang speaks
this is zach grauman
i'm one of the co-hosts of andrew yang
speaks
and this is as right now the last
episode
of 2020 what a year it has been
and look andrew doesn't take many days
off he's actually not taking the day off
today but he's taking the day off from
the podcast
um so you're stuck with me but i will
say this
the last time that yours truly hosted an
episode of andrew yang's podcast of yang
speaks
it was a top 10 episode so i don't
i don't even know i don't want to say it
but maybe i should say
that i seem to be driving most of the
downloads here so i love you guys thanks
for at least pretending to tune
in and more importantly the reason that
it actually performed well last time is
because we had good guests
and the guests we've got for today is
the wonderful carly riley
hello carly hello thanks for having me
so carly was our finance director
on the andrew yang for president
campaign
is now working at a venture fund doing
some pretty amazing stuff but why she's
here
and what we want to do today to keep
this interesting is we wanted to get out
in the universe
some bold predictions
for so we're gonna make some predictions
and andrew is making some predictions
for 2021 which i'm excited about carly i
don't know if you're excited about i
dragged you on here but i'm glad you
made it
yeah i'm i'm excited for 2021 for sure i
think
i think it can only well i'm gonna say
it can only go up from here but
i have debatable but we hope debatable
right yeah
yeah we'll see a couple things before we
get in though i am in the best mood
possible
um we're recording this on tuesday
december 29th
and my buffalo bills just
stopped on the new england patriots
stopped and it was amazing so i'm
wearing my allen diggs 20 20
t-shirt if you don't like football i
don't care
the bills have been terrible for like 20
years my whole
adult life and it was a beautiful
feeling to watch the patriots who have
been amazing for my whole adult life
to get embarrassed on national
television we could have put up 50
points we didn't
we listed our starters in the fourth
quarter but it was amazing
and stefan diggs is exceptionally
handsome so even if you don't like
football
it's worth looking up some of the
musical players yeah
yeah just for that we'll move on um but
i think this is gonna be fun
so carly let's start with what i got
from andrew
on andrews bold predictions for 2021
because i don't agree with all of them
oh all right from andrew number one
ranked choice voting in 2021 will become
a major policy
and will arrive in cities and states
around the country those who don't know
what ranked choice voting is instead of
we talk about a lot in this podcast but
just as a primer
instead of voting for one candidate and
pulling the lever you would vote for you
would rank
the candidates in the race up to as many
depending on the state so you would rank
all five of them
and then what it will do is if your
person who you voted for number one
doesn't make the top five let's say your
vote doesn't count for number one but
your number two vote would then be
counted for someone else number one so
basically like nets out all the
craziness
um it's a very fascinating policy andrew
and i have been very very
supportive i think you like this idea
too carly yeah i do like it
remind me where it already exists it
exists
in new york city this year for the first
time it is existed
in maine and i believe oregon there's a
few cities and andrew's prediction is
that it starts to go around the country
and so carly agree disagree thoughts on
the first inning prediction for 2021
agree i like it as a policy it's
interesting for me to know that it only
just became a reality in new york city i
thought it had been around for longer so
that does suggest to me that
you know it's picking up steam i'm
looking this up which states have
ranked choice voting and i mean i'll be
curious too
it sounds like yang's predicting it to
happen on like a city and state level
not a federal level which
again agree with that i don't think
we're seeing it on the national level
uh within the next year berkeley
california was the one i missed
um a couple places in colorado
oregon and maine are on here so it's
like a liberalist is using it it's a
very liberal thing
um a lot of minnesota a lot of colorado
and then
upcoming you've got alaska massachusetts
i would say i disagree i think it'll be
more popular so it's tough to
argue that because you already have much
dates but is it
does it take off i think what's going to
happen
is rank choice voting to me
gives a little power to the little guy
and gives a little power to substance it
imprisons for
third parties for outsiders i think if
ranked choice voting was on the
presidential campaign andrew would have
done very well
um because i think a lot of people liked
him
um and if their favorites were dropping
out or they maybe more people would have
voted for him number one knowing that
it wouldn't necessarily be a risky vote
um but also a lot of people liked him
it incentivized people to run on policy
and and not
um like political theater that said
if you're an incumbent or let's call it
the establishment's pick
and you've got the money and the
endorsements and
the tv ads and the powers that be behind
you
you might be able to
you would see this as a threat to your
way of life to your political dominance
and you would probably
find ways to claim that it's like in new
york they just claim that it's racist
because it's an extra step in voting and
that hurts
certain um communities of color which is
um i don't think there's any data to
back that up but you could claim there's
claims like that being made
um so i don't know my thought is that i
think it's gonna meet more opposition
because
you're actually challenging the
establishment by this i've not heard
that argument that makes no sense to me
you're still showing up to the polls and
now you're putting one two three instead
of
whatever we were doing previously that
to me seems like a
stupid argument that's being concocted
by people who want to keep this from
being a thing but maybe i'll be proved
wrong i haven't looked into that i'm
interested in
the idea of whether or not it really
does cut down on like political theater
i think celebrities probably do better
in a ranked choice voting system and
i don't know wouldn't you think like
name recognition it's like all right i
know my number
one guy my number two guy is that other
name that i heard of oh okay
you know and like i just think of
somebody like trump
obviously he won in 2016 anyways but
like
but i would say trump is less is
different than a celebrity you know what
i'm saying like trump would
trump was saying things at all there was
a general
consensus that a lot of people did not
like donald trump because he was saying
things that
they thought were racist or didn't agree
with or thought he was bucking the party
so i thought he would have been a lot of
people's one but a lot more people's
last
and such would probably lost in ranked
choice voting but i get what you're
saying someone name id
is gonna do better if they're not as
polarizing right right exactly
that's i think it does help somebody
with name id and
i don't know political theater can be a
good way to get name id your point is
that it also makes you more polarized
and therefore like if you're nasty
right right if you're a jerk is what my
point is like a lot if like
um if you're attacking all the other
candidates
maybe that knocks down your opponent peg
but also knocks you down too i'm into it
look i'm into ranked choice voting
i think it makes sense i think it'll
gain some steam
in 2021 i'm with andrew on this one
all right i think i think you'll gain
steam but i'm not as high on it as
andrew is as much i love it personally i
just think it'll hit a lot more
resistance
um especially if somebody's like losing
their power because of it and has a
pulpit and has a mouthpiece
to make a case um
okay andrew's prediction number two
he says we get cash relief in 2021
multiple times
either multiple bills or recurring cash
reliefs you're getting multiple monthly
payments
i think i agree with this one it seems
like where we're standing now cash leaf
is going to happen
um not a lot 600 bucks a person
um and i think up to 1800 or 1200 per
family i don't think it's finalized yet
and there's some more going on in the
senate as we speak
but i do think this happens and i think
the buy administration will be more
likely to drive some things through here
and it seems to be relatively bipartisan
thoughts carl i mean
look this also depends on what happens
in the georgia senate race right if
democrats have the senate i think
there's a much stronger case to be made
for this if republicans keep the senate
i think they're going to be like things
are getting better not worse
you know employment's opening back up
you know we already had to fight to get
this through
i don't know that they're going to be
into multiple payments interesting
it is a shame where this the country's
burning and we're still debating over
little scraps absurd it is absurd i
i just i i do not know how congress like
goes to bed at night feeling okay
looking at the bread lines that are
happening like looking at everything
that's going on
and like what people are dealing with
and just being like well you know we're
gonna
whatever this is not a new take but
we're gonna just push
our fight is to push through like a tax
write-off for your martini lunch or
whatever the heck that
republican add-on was for this bill and
uh you know it's tough to even blame the
rank and file congress members because
they don't even see the bill till
you know three hours before voting
starts and it's a 1700-page bill right
like it is literally
it's mitch mcconnell nancy pelosi and
donald trump right
um i mean there's a few other big
players but that's
that's the game right now yeah
yeah i did not know any of this until
y'all had that guest to explain that
that's how it works and you're like oh
well that explains that explains why our
democracy is so messed up
it's heartbreaking for those who out
there struggling um
we're sending love which is not money
but we are trying to send money
um through a number of efforts um
because talk's cheap all right
third thing from andrew gang prediction
for 2021 he's this is an interesting one
he says a third party emerges
disagree disagree yeah i'm going to
disagree the boss
yeah yeah i'm going to disagree
from the standpoint that like look it
depends on what we mean by emerge
you know what i mean i think we can
start we might start to see whispers of
something
but i think in terms of like a major
contender
i think we're a couple years out from
that
i think well why do you think that
because it's the duopoly is too strong
yeah i think the duopoly is really
strong i mean i think there'll be
there's there's interest in it but i
think uh
i just think it takes time to build
those kinds of movements and
uh i don't think it's it's done in a
year necessarily
especially a year where things are maybe
getting a bit better because the virus
is
it's true and joe is a moderate um
exactly yeah with theoretically less
polarizing but not necessarily
we haven't really talked about this i
don't think i mean andrew's floated with
a number of guests but andre and i have
not talked about
the third party that much um there's a
lot of yang yang that say andrew you
should run for a third party because the
democrats republicans never let you win
or they're just a mess and that sort of
thing and
look i have a lot of qualms with both
parties but i do think if andrew ran
as a third-party candidate for president
let's call it 2024
um it would be he would lose he'd
probably lose badly
and it would not be great and then that
party would probably die um
i think the way a third party emerges is
people have to run
at the local level um
prominent people at the local level on
these types of things and that's where i
think you're right carly that it will
not
be a year thing it will take some time
but i don't know look i'm
all for breaking up the duopoly i think
at this point they are
industries and as long as they are
industries with their own profit
motivation which is what they each kind
of have
um you know you're kind of doomed yeah
so i think we have a serious need for
one maybe that's why
you know i i want one so i don't want to
get my my hopes up
i think i i think we're we're right for
it but um our system just also like our
like the framing like from our founding
we've had two parties right like our
system is
is set up to have two so i think if it
if a third party emerges it's
it's going to have to replace one of the
existing two parties because
right we're just not set up to be a
system with three competitive parties
which is why i think andrew's
predictions are interesting with ranked
choice voting
would set the stage for multiple
political parties
because you have a real chance to win
see he's so comprehensive
this is you work for andrew long enough
and you realize like everything starts
to connect with everything else and he
has like a a cohesive world view
and this is why he should run things
because
he sees things holistically it's so
funny like
you know you you want to bring things to
your boss
like new ideas or things like this but
i've always learned with andrew like if
you're going to bring some to andrew you
better be ready to
freaking defend it because he'll just
school you he'll just
he'll just you know it'll just it'll rip
you apart if you're wrong and not not
like in a
mean way uh he'll just very
systematically
lay it off just exactly like it's
supposed to be immediately
like oh yeah yeah i'm gonna go back into
my little hole and just do what you told
me
i will just i see you've cut to the core
here i'm fairly embarrassed next next
thought
um which is and he's a and the thing is
that he's a very good listener too it's
not like he's going to do that if you're
right you're golden you know he's like a
lot more sense
yeah he's a great boss he's good to
learn from
um but you better become ready to play
better ready to play speaking of ready
to play what are your predictions
my first one is that we fully reopen
vaccine
vaccinated society essentially back to
business
september 21 september 2021
we start the roaring 20s and you start
travel stores are opening sports
dating people get all excited i was
seeing an article about this
that people are gonna have because
became a big thing in the 1920s
apparently which again was
after the 1918 pandemic so you see this
like
that like part of the roaring 20s in the
1920s was a result of
the pandemic of 19 pent up and it was
like you know you had the flapper
dresses this was like
the uh one era of sort of like women's
sexual liberation like pre the pill
of like little flapper dresses and the
rest of it and apparently orgies were a
thing
so i so you're saying september 2021 is
when
that is wow but i do predict a a two you
know 21st century version of the roaring
20s starting
september 2021 okay i think it'll be
earlier okay i
i agree right i think clearly we're
gonna open up again in 2021 and it's
gonna be
madness madness on the dating apps um
but i think i think it'll come sooner
because we have
so all the high-risk people are being
they're trying to get them all
vaccinated in the first half of the year
right if the high priority people have
been vaccinated by june
say in those first six months like if
they fulfill that timeline
then i mean really try and stop people
from like going and raging in the summer
like and you know we don't have to just
talk about the party scene obviously
there's work and other things so there's
twofold challenges on this sort
there's governments are forcing things
to be closed which we can agree or
disagree with depending on the location
and timing and things like that but
there's also just there is a lack of
demand
right like right now people are there's
plenty of restaurants in the south that
are
allowed to stay open and they're hurting
because people are not going out to eat
or traveling and tourism is down and all
these things
so this this a notion on the right in
particular that
the government is forcing things to be
terrible is is not fully true there is a
global pandemic and people are scared
um so i do think if you can get the fear
down
you then have a better demand that will
force governments to follow suit i don't
think governments are really set up to
lead in
the 21st century right now so i think
but i
look i'd love it to be earlier i think
um i i guess i think governments will
see how good summer goes and then
start to open back up in the fall and
feel better about the the numbers going
down the vaccinations going up
what's what's your first thing what's
your like what is the thing you miss
mosaic what are you trying to do
i will be at i think i'll just go to the
buffalo bills stadium
oh i set that one up so perfectly
justice yeah of course you want
to soak it in we're finally good and i
can't go to a game
you know what i'm saying i bought season
tickets they're not that doesn't i'm not
rich
uh i just spend the little spending
money i have on the cheap season tickets
and i split them with my brother but
i can't go i can't go it's so so yeah i
think i would just show up in buffalo
yeah and just hang out anyway what's the
first thing you do
oh oh i asked this question i should
have been prepared to have it flipped on
me i don't know i'd probably just like a
big old
restaurant indoor scene with like all my
favorite people like let's just go
all hug each other up inside somewhere i
don't know you're gonna have the orgy
jesus no no no like a friend a friend
you're already here that was weird
oh boy oh boy gosh we might have to cut
this out
okay um thank you carl all right what's
up
what's your prediction first prediction
joe biden
by executive order cancels let's call it
ten thousand dollars
of federal student loan debt yeah
whoa yeah oh yeah there's so much
on this we have not yet so let's crack
this can of worms okay
there's so much here again
will he do this recently he's indicated
maybe he wants to try and do like
canceling student loan debt
via like legislation as opposed to by
executive order
in which case again we're kind of
waiting around to see what happens at
the georgia senate
runoff but i think the case for
canceling student loan debt is even
stronger if you do it by executive order
right
because you know i people are kind of
mixed on the whole cancelling student
loan debt
yes they are question because they say
it's regressive they say you're just
benefiting you know the elites
anyway correct and my feeling is like
look
first of all it depends how you do it if
you only cancel undergraduate debt
it actually becomes you know it's
benefiting a lot of people who are in
the middle and like lower middle classes
as well and
frankly something that's helping the
middle class right now is certainly
something we should be thinking about
right um but
you know if you're saying should we
cancel student loan debt or should we
pass another stimulus check for folks
i'm 100 going stimulus check that's
where you're going to hit you know
people who have less money for people
i'd rather give cash but you think
biden's going to do this thing
and why is it a good idea well this is
what i'm saying so
it's a good idea because it is something
right because he can do it it looks like
he can do it by executive order
right that's why it's so awesome because
look at the end of the day it is
it is a stimulus right you're gonna you
have a lot of people this is there's
been a lot made of this right like
people our age not buying homes because
they're related with student loan debt
you can take that burden off people's
backs we are going to spend money more
we are going to engage in the economy
more so it is a stimulus it's not the
perfect stimulus in my mind
but the problem is the perfect stimulus
that i want just took eight months to
pass and i'm not convinced we're going
to get republicans
it's also just so interesting the whole
argument about what
about whether or not he can do this by
executive order is a really interesting
one
like this basically goes back the reason
people are making this argument is
because of this
decision obama made in 2010 where he cut
out all the middlemen like the private
middlemen
in um federal like with federal student
loan debt
and it's just such a good example of
like these little things that presidents
do that probably didn't mean anything to
us at the time
that later on have huge implications and
it's like yes i've been reading one
president
after joe biden what president wants to
be the [ __ ] that says
just kidding it's not cancelled yeah
you know it just won't happen yeah well
yeah they just you know the basically
the department of justice or the
department of education can just decide
like
not to collect this money um now some
people i think warren or or others
i think want it to be like all cancelled
that that's going a little far to me i
think
i think you cap it at 10k or maybe you
uh
there's like it's means tested though
i'm not i don't tend to be a fan of
means-tested things because
but you could do for only undergraduate
which would avoid a lot of people going
to med school or law school
don't particularly need it and their
jobs will pay for it anyway yeah
i think you only undergraduate and and
really then there are a lot of
working-class people that you're you're
majorly benefiting um
so so i'm totally in favor uh especially
again if you can do it by executive
order it's something like bring it on
like just like you know
let's get something i am here so i'll
say this i had
around 200 grand in student loans when i
was 22 or so and most of those were not
federal
um because we i was in that horrible
zone where your parents made some money
so
uh you couldn't qualify for any public
loans but not enough to ever pay for
college
um so you had to go to college on just
all debt in all private debt
um which you know i i understand why but
it's still never fun
um and so
and we're talking like you you graduate
day one and like your first payment's
due
pretty quickly and it's 800 to a
thousand dollars right it's
that's a massive payment um
and um so for me
i you know i i worked them off like i
you know i
um i sold my soul for 10 years on wall
street
and um you know it was rough it i didn't
make a lot of money at first but over
time i took every bonus i got
which wasn't as big as people would
think a wall street bonus was but it was
this was sizable to eventually get
200 grand and knock it out over
essentially a decade
so i would be very very happy
for all the people getting out of debt i
would be very very happy i think from an
economic standpoint i think it's the
right like if you're trying to get the
weight off of
a younger generation it probably makes
the most sense
but it also would frustrate me because
there's a reason i didn't major in
theater and things i was passionate
about
because i was a theater there's a reason
i didn't major in stuff that wasn't
going to pay the bills
was because there's a reason i took that
job on wall street now generally i liked
a lot of my people there and i did learn
a lot but i wouldn't have picked that
um i would have worked to teach for
america i think um so
wow that would frustrate different you
never would have found andrew yang
that's probably true who knows who knows
but my point is
i mean and maybe people listening to
like boohoo's act like people are
struggling which you're probably right
but i
i imagine the people who have paid it
off
or have worked their ass off and made
life choices that were really
challenging and maybe against their
wills and passions and best interests in
many ways
to get out of debt it is like uh enough
come on oh i fully expect everybody
who's paid off their debt to be jealous
and they have every right to be we
should still do it
in lieu of nothing else being possible
because i'm that guy
i'm the person that should be the most
jealous in terms of like didn't come for
money
worked his ass off to pay them off you
know yeah
though you weren't gonna be helped with
this anyway because you didn't have
federal loans
that's true you're sort of out of the
question that's true you know
we can only really cancel federal debt
but i'm saying whatever just do it like
at some point like
what the analogy i heard is like uh
i don't know it's like everybody else
should suffer because i had to it's not
right
it's a terrible way to society
yeah just start meditating or something
and get over it but people have made
dumb decisions with their money
in terms of there's people that have
gone to very expensive schools with no
foreseeable path forward afterwards a
ton of debt
you know you and i were both in this
position you're 18 years old you're kind
of
following the people are telling you
it's so important to go to a good school
there's social pressure around what
college you go to sort of where i was
for instance and
and you're 18. like what the heck do you
know you have like no concept of like
what it means to leave with debt and
i think that we don't see financial
literacy so nobody's equipped this
actually will tie well into my next
prediction but
you know none of us are equipped i am
curious to know what people have been
doing during this time where there has
been this moratorium on student loan
payments
i still have student loan debt and and
i've been fortunate enough to have a job
but i actually haven't been
i haven't been making my payments
because there's no interest accruing
because i've been sort of under this
idea of like cash is king right now
um so i've been saving that money but i
kind of wanted on i was like waiting for
the apocalypse to come and i wanted to
like you know have my
my shekels saved for like you know get a
shotgun
yeah i'm y2k stocked up yeah i get it
yeah
so that was sort of my my thinking on it
though and and now i'm waiting because
i'm like well man if he wipes this stuff
out
uh that's yeah i would be super right
prediction
carly riley is that we wipe out 10k
student loan debt you guys
if you have 10k in federal loans
better hope carly's right don't pay yet
they'll pay yeah
apparently the first hundred days to see
what happens
all right if you're like me or let's say
it like anybody
in this pandemic your mental health is
probably going for a
bit of a roller coaster ride not being
able to see friends not be able to go
out
uh your job is probably different i know
these feelings i've had on myself
and it's one of the reasons why i'm
happy
to be sponsored by betterhelp for this
podcast because
they've got some really great tools and
a great tech platform to assist you with
this mental health
challenge while going through so
betterhelp will assess your needs and
match you with your own
licensed professional therapist so you
can connect in this kind of safe
very personal private online environment
it's very convenient and you can start
communicating you sign up you start
communicating another 24 hours pretty
cool so it's not really self-help it's
just professional
counseling so you can send a message to
your counselor anytime
you get timely thoughtful responses plus
you schedule weekly
video or phone session so you can kind
of do it at your own schedule
and you never have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room you don't
need to tell anybody
um it's honestly pretty great and it's
they've got licensed professionals for
anywhere and anything that includes
depression stress anxiety relationships
sleeping trauma anger family conflicts
lgbt matters
grief self-esteem for me it was energy
and
purpose and frankly just someone to talk
to it's great um
everything and anything you share is
confidential and it's convenient
professional
and affordable so i want you guys to
check this out um
because they're our sponsor and we're
proud to be sponsored by them on this
podcast so
if you want to start living a happier
life today as a listener of yang speaks
because they're sponsoring us you get 10
off your first month by visiting
betterhelp.com
yang that's better help
b-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p-dot-com
yang join over one million people who've
taken charge of their mental health like
me
that's betterhelp.com yang
[Music]
[Applause]
all right here's my second prediction
i'm predicting a
significant fall in
our educational institutions
participatingly
college while we're talking about
college does that mean like lower
enrollment
just the current generation just got a
raw deal where
like they were supposed to and it just
like cut to the bone of what you
actually pay for in college and what
matters so these kids are having to pay
like 60k a year
um they're not getting a college
experience
um because they're not on campus they're
not growing socially and that sort of
thing
and um
they are taking all their classes online
usually at home or if they're
in the college town they are distance
and that sort of thing and i think it'll
change the way
employers and people look at the purpose
of college if you want to go for like a
social
development situation that'll be a
luxury item like summer camp for kids
who are you know leaving their home at
18 but if you want to go and just like
get to work there will be way more
options
in the uh basically in the marketplace
um from because of technology and its
improvement and i would even argue
that your big tech companies will enter
this space your amazon's facebook
your youtube google situation
where and i think scott galloway is
someone we really love has talked a lot
about this um in the past it's like
that's one of the only places that
those companies can actually get sizable
growth that's ripe for disruption in the
tech space
and it's been it's been hard to do in
the past but those brands have all been
hurt
and look at now like sports has changed
college sports has changed
that that tide is shifting i think in
terms of how we look at college athletes
so look that's my prediction i think
these education the
lure of educational institutions as
someone who went to one with it
somewhat of an allure i think it's gonna
start fading um i think a lot of people
always pay for like the best of the best
maybe um but i think it'll change yeah
yeah okay i like this i
think i think higher education so
desperately needs a shake-up
what that looks like i i you know who
knows exactly
i think i'm totally with andrew on the
fact that we need fewer people going to
four-year colleges and we need to weigh
up the trade school quota
and getting people into jobs that are
less
right for automation i think the second
piece to this is just
a need to democratize higher education
uh and you brought up scott galloway so
i'm gonna talk about him too i have to
usually limit myself to how much i can
talk about scott galloway or i would do
basically nothing but talk about scott
galloway um
okay so you you've you've opened to the
way which is
he i think section four is his newest
venture
um and it's all about democratizing
higher education
his point is we have stopped recognizing
like that professors and these
educational institutions have stopped
seeing themselves as public servants
and started to see themselves as luxury
goods and that that is so backwards
right
it talks about harvard has this like 39
whatever it is billion dollar endowment
or where the heck the harvard endowment
is
and the the admission officer you know
the head of admissions is like bragging
about the fact that they could double
the size of the incoming freshman class
but they don't
you know saying like oh there are so
many good applicants and his point is
like why don't you like double the size
of the incoming freshman class then you
have more money than you could ever need
why are we not
like bringing more sort of smart
qualified people
into this fold why are we treating this
like sexual luxury item
41 billion dollars 41 billion dollars
like
that they can afford i don't really
understand how big a billion is but
scott's very much in favor of getting
more people
i do you know ivy league educations put
whatever stock in that you can
and then i'm a big proponent of of then
also getting
more people into trade schools and trade
programs i think we totally need to
rethink this whole thing
and i think you're right that we will
have to move in that direction the role
of big tech is interesting i've looked
very little into that
but i i think they've been they're
looking for growth they're like they're
you know um they're getting into media
and i think education is a big one too
and one that they can do
um like does that mean amazon starts a
university
i don't know but specifically for
certain tech jobs or whatever it is i
mean
you could see this all over the place um
like facebook trying to bring into their
i mean that's their own company or other
tech companies you get a facebook
certificate and coding or
customer service or [ __ ] like that like
imagine
like that to me is almost a better brand
than harvard like i got this kid that
knows exactly what a tech company like
facebook needs in ad sales or i've got a
liberal arts degree from harvard
so um i mean think about that that's
wild yeah um
wild and you're totally and if they're
working remotely and like do the social
skills matter as much
i don't know like that's usually one of
the things you're going to be a harvard
man you're going to be a duke man
whatever the hell
or whatever the you know you get what
i'm saying and that there's this sort of
brand and allure to the university i
don't think that's gonna matter as much
and i think
my prediction is that it happens way
faster than you think
i think it happens like these
universities they'll be fine they've got
billions of dollars in their endowment
they probably have to fire a bunch of
people and other things but um
i think this the traditional educational
path as we know it will start to crumble
and shift that's my prediction what
about you carl number two
all right number two i think
robin hood the trading app precipitates
the financial crisis not the charity
which i've also been working with
recently
robin hood the trading app causes a
financial crisis among millennials
like very similar to the way subprime
mortgage lenders
messed everything up in the lead up to
2008. okay
a little bit of a doomsday so for those
of you who don't understand where
robinhood is i'll give you the dumb
version then carlo give you the smart
version so robin hood
if is a investment app
so you can trade real money in the stock
market
um on your phone so similar to what
e-trade is or what fidelity yeah they're
an electronic broker
but it's on your phone and it's designed
the way facebook is it's designed with
silicon valley engineers to make it
addictive and fun and gamified except
it's real money um so
just just for those of you who have not
downloaded i'm we are not encouraging
you
in particular to download
robinhood but this is a real thing and
it's very very popular
i would be interested to know what
percent of the yang speaks audience
doesn't know robin hood because by the
numbers
most of us are are on it if we're
millennials no
i i don't know there's no the answer
audience is diverse carl don't don't you
do
not just millennials sorry sorry sorry
no offense if you're a standard
millennial listening
but we go across the spectrum keep going
yeah yeah okay fair
genders you name it all right here's the
thing robinhood has
exploded so i first downloaded robin
hood in 2014
and i should say i am a robin hood user
so this is not to like
knock robin hood wholesale right i think
i think the idea that we need more
people like kind of smartly
operative word invested in the stock
market is
is obvious and true right because you
look at wealth inequality income
inequality so much of this is driven by
the fact that such a small percent of
americans
participate in the stock market the
problem with robin hood specifically is
they have lured in
all of these young people because they
were the first platform to say
commission free trading we won't
charge you when you place a trade and to
the point zac made they had this like
fun silicon valley
gamified user interface that triggers
all of like the dopamine centers that
you know like facebook and instagram so
it's a social media app
um and the problem right now is you're
luring on all these young people
who are myself included novice investors
who don't really know what we're doing
we're pouring a bunch of money into
companies like tesla and peloton
companies i love but let's be honest
like they have valuations there the
funds yeah they're story stocks
tesla you know they have valuations that
are above the fundamentals
well peloton you know tesla's very cool
too but you have elon elon musk
literally earlier this year but
don't buy it uh oh no you're just like
oh yeah i think we're like a little
overvalued like elon musk
is the most confident dude don't buy my
company and he's like yeah i feel like
this valuation is like a little high
and like pete and the stock went up like
40 the next week like nobody's paying
attention to any like nobody's listening
to anything
so so i think we are very clearly in a
story stock bubble
that is very connected to robin hood and
the robin hood user base
uh i there's a there's an instagram like
influencer i follow
called literally her her name is girl
with no job
and she posted recently on her story a
dm she had received from somebody being
like
oh my god thanks for recommending like
chewy stock i just invested and it's
exploded like it's my best stock in the
portfolio
and you're like god this is a case study
in bubbles it's like
stock advice from girl with no job who
is very smart this is not a knock on her
but like we are in a bubble with certain
stocks
the story the simple story of 2008 which
anybody who watched the big short knows
is that subprime mortgage lenders pushed
mortgages on a lot of people who
couldn't afford them right
but like you know high mortgages that
people couldn't afford to pay
and as long as housing prices were going
up this worked fine because people would
refinance they could then continue to
pay off their mortgage
it wasn't a problem and there was this
whole narrative that
mortgage and home prices will never go
down they'll never fall
right this was like this the great you
know fraud that was being
the great line that was being like
perpetrated and
of course eventually housing prices did
start to fall people no longer could
afford their mortgages
and there was this whole crisis that
ensued because these shady brokers
had pushed leverage and pushed mortgages
on people who couldn't afford them
this is what is happening with robin
hood robin hood is pushing people to
make to actively trade
way more than is really sensible but
worse they're pushing margin on people
which means they're giving people access
they're loaning users money it is very
easy to trade on margin with robinhood
robinhood will loan you money to make
trades right
anytime your loan money you have to pay
that money back and you have to pay it
back with interest
right now stocks are going up so the
impact of people trading on margin is
not being felt
that will eventually stop and you are
going to have
a really really bad situation where you
have young people who didn't really know
what they were doing
hold it having traded on margin and
being stuck with a bill
way beyond what they can afford they're
also pushing people to get into options
trading which is another
way riskier you know type of trading
that a lot of people
don't understand and it's also going to
leave people holding the bag and there
are lawsuits
around this very fact happening right
now massachusetts is suing them because
they're saying you can't gamify this and
push this on people
um so that's where it's very similar to
2008 and we're gonna have some
some bad outcomes come 2021. if they've
been loan money
and then they are riding this bull
market and making money
is the issue like when things start to
go down and they keep getting loan money
and then they start losing it or they
already made enough money are they
playing with house money at this point
because the market's doing so well
no well this is what connects to they're
invested in companies that are
eventually going to collapse or
collapse not the right word they're
invested in companies whose valuations
are going to go down because the
valuations are way too high because they
haven't cashed out i see
right because they're driving it up and
if you start investing in a bull market
like this you get very confident it's
impossible to avoid i feel it right
you're like
maybe i'm kind of good at this i keep
making money stocks keep going up and
you have that feeling
like in 2008 the sense that housing
prices are never going to go down you
start to feel like stock prices aren't
going to go down
dave portnoy i mean he's doing it to be
funny but he says this all the time
yeah barcelona the founder of
barcelona's like stocks can't go down
stocks only go up
and you see that oh like people have
that kind of feeling when they ride a
huge bull market and so these valuations
are way too high they're going to go
down and people are going to be
really financially hurt by it so there
it is you heard it from carly
robin hood and just like the millennial
entrance
into the financial markets through robin
hood
is going to hit millennials the hardest
and some sort of financial collapse is
what you're predicting i get that right
sure i'll you know i don't think this
will necessarily be on something on the
scale of 2008 but i think
millennials are going to be going to be
burned by robin hood let's say that
in 2021 when stocks finally start to
come back down to a sane level
very cool all right um
my third prediction niche players in the
media space starting to emerge
um so i think you're already seeing this
with
the success of a number of podcasts um
and
personalities doing well in that space
but i think it's deeper than that where
it's
uh sub stack uh is a big one for a lot
of journalists
um and then i think parlor which is the
right wing social media app apparently
the tech is pretty terrible
but i think that's just the beginning
um i think you're going to have ratings
hurt in a lot of these major media
companies
which means they'll either start getting
desperate and start getting more like
hyper focused and partisan
or people are going gonna start taking
their place um
i don't think we end up in a world where
everybody subscribes to their own little
things
i do think eventually this will be
consolidated and even
um there may be some
even regulation around this particularly
on our social media companies that are
driving a lot of the divisiveness but i
do think
you're going to have a rise of small and
eventually larger
new types of media empires um that's my
prediction
thoughts yes 100 percent
curious one of them might be yang speaks
well gang speaks would fall into that
category of of
kind of niche i think what you have
happening is this fragmentation right
you have
matthew iglesias and ezra klein leaving
vox the media company they built
you have matt taibi leaving rolling
stone to start a sub stack i mean you
have
this this kind of barry weiss leaving
the new york times you have this mass
exodus of sort of
individual reporters um you have this
rise in podcasts and sub stacks and
and and so i have a very like curated
media diet
you know like like scott galloway who i
read you know anytime he has a
newsletter but
you know i follow a lot of sub stackers
so at this point my media diet
is very much the one that i curate um
and this is working for me for now
um but i do think there's something to
be said for
like bigger organizations that can
kind of scoop up these fragmented
players and and bring them all under one
roof
um so i think that would be very
interesting to see
news which is kind of what we're
flirting with here news should not
just be entertainment it should not just
be candy it should not just be what we
want
it also needs to be what we need what we
need to know
um it needs to be vegetables like no one
at least has a kid you don't love
vegetables but you need to have them um
and we haven't gotten that in a long
time
um and there are journalists out there
that are giving it but there is
probably still value in this curation of
that's why editors used to exist to kind
of
balance your diet of news to keep with
my
food analogy so i um i just think my
prediction is that this all gets
disrupted like this is the time
like trump was the the dam that was
holding
them together him being gone will break
it um
that may he may be one of the people
that start that if he goes and starts a
social media company for himself
he would be huge um or a media firm or
that sort of thing and that'll cause a
lot of responses i'm not sure
but i think pretty feeling pretty strong
that something happened there
particularly post covid too the rise of
like alternative social media
terrifies me like if we get to a point
where you know republicans and democrats
already don't speak to each other very
well if we get to the point where we are
on our own sort of ideologically
separated
platforms i think it's devastating i
will say because i'm so concerned about
this i signed up for parlor just to like
keep tabs on what was happening i've
checked it all about once
the signing up for parlor process was
stu was a nightmare it like the tech was
terrible
it's a terrible platform so i'm not sure
that parlor throat pose as much of a
threat
but you know if that were to happen and
maybe it can't because these companies
are just too big and everybody's on them
but
um i think that's a terrifying prospect
because that's at least the one place we
all are
even if we're living in our own silos
within them um
we're at least under the same the same
roof it's um
i'm going to try one of my goals if much
as possible is to and we haven't been
doing it recently
um but i want to be better about making
helping our audience members eat their
vegetables you know i'd like to come to
hear
news that is that i think you need to
know we all need to know and it's
terrifying for me and i think you too
you're saying is like i
consider myself a well-informed voter or
citizen
but there's times i'm just like i don't
think i'm getting direct perspectives
here
and it's hard you're one of the best
people i know and like trying to find
new sources of info and always reading
always trying to better yourself and
learn well i will say i don't go to any
institutions
to know what i want to know i go to
india you go to people and that's what's
striking
yeah i no longer go to it there's pros
and cons to that right
um there's a lot of pros in some ways
but there's some constitution that's one
human right
there's a lot of power for personality
um okay
carl last prediction oh last prediction
uh i think security deposits are going
to
become a thing of the past whether that
happens entirely in 2021
i won't say but i think we are going to
see their descent into obsolescence
and big cities if you have these
security positions on your apartment
they're going away
yep and this is a bit of a personal
project this is something i'm working on
at my company so this was a selfish pick
but i i actually think it's very selfish
i think
you're showing for how you shilled and
andrew shield we're all chilling
we showed for freshly which is very good
there are 45 billion dollars in security
deposits
locked up around the country right now
uh which is a fascinating
number that i did not know 45 billion
dollars
dang yeah okay so this is that's a
harvard endowment
yeah it's bigger than the harvard
endowment and it's our money
sitting in escrow accounts you can't get
interest right you can't invest it right
so this is what i say landlords aren't
even
it benefits landlords because they stay
protected from damages to their property
but they can't earn interest on it so
the only thing it's doing is protecting
them but there are other ways to do that
so for instance when you lease a car
you don't put down a security deposit
you get car insurance
and you know so again i'm working with a
company that does this it's an insurance
alternative to
security deposits i'm renting an
apartment right now i'm going through
the process
i'm choosing to use rhino and to use a
monthly insurance payment plan as
opposed to a security deposit
because i don't want that money locked
up and by the way one in four renters
don't get their security deposit back
this is another industry that is to me
just right for disruption
once you start thinking about it you
can't unthink it it's right once you
realize security deposits make no sense
you like can't unlearn that information
and then
looking for an apartment now it's
terrible you're like i owe you what
and why and what are you going to do
with that money you're just going to sit
on it
to make sure i'm not an [ __ ] right
right and
you know you get it there's other ways
to do that when you're introduced to the
concept you're like yeah i guess this is
just how it works
and it should not have to be that way so
i think this this concept of replacing
security deposits makes way too much
sense
you keep the landlord protected renters
don't have to lock up their money for
eternity until they buy a home basically
and uh it makes way too much sense to
not gain
gain traction it's gonna happen okay so
carly your predictions to recap you've
got an executive order canceling
student loan 10k in federal student loan
debt robin hood
screwing over millennials and security
deposits going away
by the end of the year no more security
or just starts to go no no we're yeah
you're going to see the rise in the
obsolescence
i love that word of security
obsolescence wow for those of you who
didn't go to whatever liberal
institution carly crawled out of
uh obsolescence means obsolete
and my predictions are we fully reopen
we owe reopen in september 2021 our
educational institutions as we know them
start to change
and new media players are going to start
to rise and andrews as you remember as
you know ranked choice voting cash
relief
and a third party coming out so it's
pretty tight this is kind of a cool
situation let's end with a um i'll give
you one more call give me a fun one
uh that's less serious than security
deposits obsolescence
[Laughter]
taylor swift my girl she came out with
two albums
in quarantine as we all should know by
this point i'm saying she does something
really cool and different and creative
when things open up again
like some sort of like outdoor intimate
secret folklore evermore concert because
they're both very like
socially distant or is this no no we're
talking the world opens up again it's
all
safe and she she's like you know i see
her on like a lawn chair
like with flowing hair like strumming an
acoustic guitar and like nobody knows
about it until it breaks on social media
like three months later
we're running this back in december of
2021 okay
uh see this is to hold us accountable
who's the most famous
and um my prediction is that the bills
buffalo bills go to the afc championship
i wanna say they're gonna win the super
bowl
but i i
i don't wanna jinx it okay so what we're
gonna do is
we're gonna bet on this thing because we
have to that's the way this this works
we have some skin in the game
um so and it'll be a long time between
now and then but we will check in on
these
so and andrew doesn't know but i'm gonna
commit him to whatever we wager so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna ask you
guys what you think we should bet
and then we'll circle back next week and
decide so if you have an idea what we
should bet if we think carly should i
don't know
have to wear a josh allen jersey and run
around football pads
okay and you have to wear that a taylor
swift t-shirt or something i maybe maybe
we can do this
i'm just saying so these are the crazy
ideas what does andrew do andrew has to
where josh allen and taylor's do both
he has to sing and taylor swift's song
and josh allen jersey uh i don't know
um so use the hashtag
yankspeaks wager that's where i go with
hashtag yangspeakswager
and give us your thoughts on twitter on
instagram i'll look at both
um carly we'll look at both we'll find
the good ones
yang speeds wager all right yank speech
wager we'll make him do something stupid
well yang's probably gonna be right and
yeah of course
andrew's favorite i'm stupid taylor
swift's song i'm pretty sure is i don't
want to live forever
you learned this on the campaign well it
was funny because on the campaign trail
on the presidential campaign trail he
would always be like this one's for
carly because he knew i loved taylor
swift
and it would always be i don't want to
live forever so my hypothesis is that
happened to be
andrew's also favorite taylor swift song
so
blah blah blah is that like if you're
listening this whole episode you're
getting some easter eggs it's great
so andrew would love to dj especially in
the early days when we would drive our
own car
back and forth from new hampshire and he
only had like
a handful of basically songs from
the 80s from his college days 80s and
90s
um like downloaded on his phone because
he had like
itunes essentially on his phone so we
would listen to like
jetblack heart and the script and
not the script who was he who do you
love like there's
i feel like there's like a melissa
etheridge song he loves like i feel like
didn't he like barracuda i feel like he
loves the song
like all the like it was just like
yang's deep cut deep tracks like these
songs like what are you really listening
to what was this
angry men he's got like some angry men
that like sing passionately
um he does have pretty cool music tastes
but uh
all right for those who made it these
are our bold predictions for 2021
would love to hear your predictions as
well you can always use ask yank speaks
as a hashtag to tell us but i really
want you to use
yankspeak's wager and let's bet on these
bad boys and tell us what idiotic things
we could do
um when i or i want really want carly to
do the dumb stuff because i'm definitely
gonna be right
thank you all for listening we love you
to death have a happy new year let's
please for the love of god make 2021
better than 2020 bye guys
amen happy new year thank you for
listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation
if you did please do subscribe to
yangspeeks and click on notifications so
we can let you know
every time we have a new episode
you